let's talk about this book I am very
impressed you wrote these essays they're
very funny they're they're very well
done you've got a great pro style you
and and there's some really fun ones you
you wouldn't necessary R
smiling tricks your brain into thinking
it's happy oh right and that I really
loved you actually kind of wrote a more
of a story than an essay is very funny
do you think that's did you get that
title from something you actually think
is true or has heard it that it's true
I think it's false like it's the kind of
thing that I think like a crazy person
ends up doing like they smile I also
tend to not trust anybody's who's
smiling because I imagine they've just
killed somebody I think like anytime you
see anyone smiling yes you think they've
just murdered someone
I associate smiling exclusively with
derangement yeah yeah I think if
somebody's really happy in a real way
they'll probably kind of keep it in and
there might be like a kind of maybe an
upturned lip just slightly but a full
smile seems nuts right yeah and so I'm
right this is a story about a guy who
uses this what I think of as kind of a
silly idea of smiling tricking a brain
if they like to kind of commit crimes
and live a horrible life but he's
smiling throughout the whole thing
do you have you ever tried you ever had
someone tell you because if someone
didn't know you I have this situation
where because I think I'm on television
a lot and people see this a lot if I'm
when I remembered when I was living in
New York I would walk along and if my
face just went neutral like yes this
your man would walk out and go mr.
O'Brien oh yeah
cheer up it'll be okay right no I'm fine
I'm just trying to remember what my wife
told me to get at the grocery store
they'd be like don't be sad don't kill
yourself and I'm like going on I'm
really okay but they they didn't see
this guy walking down the street why are
the doorman outside because they're bad
dorm oh I see what Wilson that's all
then they were just trolling the streets
looking for unhappy unhappy television
hosts you must have that sometimes where
people think because you can look when
you're neutral you look a little intense
and maybe a little unhappy this is
what's great
I play unhappy people and when people
see me and I'm not weeping or trying to
kill like Superman they think I'm having
a great day
see you should just play a villain on
your show I know yes and that well there
are certain celebrities that are famous
for being a Serb akin tough you know
right and you know and like great actor
like Sean Penn but like he's punched
people in his past right like that and
when he punches someone they're almost
like wow cool I got punched by Sean yes
exactly exactly but if I do that people
are like hey that didn't hurt at all I
think he hurt his hand
Conan's okay and I think a small pinata
just hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography